[Musique]
tu es pratiquement jamais à la maison
quand elle arrive pas à fermer l'oeil
et combien de fois par nuit est ce que
ton point ça dure
je vois le mal que tu t'impliques pour
te remettre sur pied j'essaie de
maintenir la paix
qu'est ce que je suis censé faire j'ai
pas donner la liste
et quoi qu'il en coûte je me bats pour
mes convictions
pourquoi kidal
tout ce que je veux c'est faire mon
devoir frère je ne m'attendais pas à te
voir ici nous savons à discuter d'
histoire de famille davos et toi
vous êtes entraînés ensemble
j'ai combattu mon frère on ne peut pas
changer ce qui est arrivé tu as
l'impression d'avoir le droit de faire
ce que tu veux lancement comme s'il
était tout à port lay ron office ce
n'est pas une norme qu'on brandit une
arme
[Musique]
lord durham de lescure et de revenir à
ma naissance
[Musique]
c'est fini tu as
pour l'iphone fist pas beau ce goulet
on peut l'arrêter et je peux pas y
arriver seul vous n'êtes pas fait
écoute quoi que tu fasses tu sauveras
pas toujours je peux pas rester assis là
rien faire
je suis maintenant derrière
t'as jamais eu la force de tenir
mais l'histoire de demain s'écrit
aujourd'hui
à vous décrire
on pourrait faire ça plus souvent dîner
dehors sur un film
[Musique]
rendez vous romantique